well there there's a recall election for
governor coming here and a friend of
yours caitlyn jenner is running
um so does that make it easier or harder
to decide who to support because i know
in all seriousness
it's a completely different job than
when you're acting and it's a big
undertaking
you know and and it's a lot of work so
is it is it hard for you when it's a
friend or is it easier for you to be
like
no i'm going to cut the crap i'm going
to tell you this like is it is it easy
or hard for you
well it's not easy or hard it makes no
difference to me
uh because the fact of the matter is is
that i stay out of the race
uh as i've said many times i said that
gavin newsom is a friend of mine
uh caitlyn is a friend of mine a lot of
other people that may run
and will announce friends of mine but i
don't get involved
because you know i have the usc
schwarzenegger institute
which is the bipartisan institute uh
kind of like a think tank in the way we
talk about various important issues of
healthcare
infrastructure environmental issues
homeless issues and so on and so forth
so the only way you really can do that
successfully is
if you're able to bring democrats and
republicans that are experts
in the various different subjects
together so therefore i don't want to
get involved in
a political arena at all i don't you
know support democrats or to support
republicans but i said i stay out of it
i think that's really important that
think tank that's a really important
i mean on a global level i think that's
important that
no matter what our beliefs are no matter
what your you know principles the core
thing is that everyone wants to be happy
um healthy you want to be able to get
your kids healthy and get you know
health care and and and all that so i
think that that think tank idea is
that's what really needs to happen
regardless of what
political side of the fence you land on
want more fun stuff
i thought so check out these videos
floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure